السوق المتارجحه او الشهيره بالتقلبات
الهائله ثروات تظهر وتختفي بين ليله
وضحاها هل عرفتم عن اي سوق نتحدث طبعا سوق
العملات المشفره متقلبه هي لكن ليس لدرجه
ما حدث هذا الاسبوع تبخرت شركه عملاقه او
تكاد كما تبخرت مليارات صاحبها ال 15
نتحدث عن شركه اف تي اكس العملاقه وعن
صاحبها سام بانك من فرايد صاحب ال 30 عاما
ان هي شو بها ابن انهيار بانك لمن براذرز
عام 2008 الذي اثار ظهرا ماليا عالميا بل
ازمه عالميا لاحقا حاولت اكستفادي سقوط
واعرضها بانك مان فرايد على منافسه
الصينيه
وعلى شركته العملاقه باينهز بالفعل قبل
الاخير العرض ثم تراجع لتنهار امبراطوريه
بانك رايدر الرقميه
مع من اكبر البورصتين عالميا عملياتها
غامضه الى حد ما ليس لها مقر رسمي وتسيطر
حاليا على ما يقرب من نصف سوق تبادل
العملات المشفره ولها مشكله كبيره مع
بلدان عده في العالم اما اف تي اكس فيقع
مقرها الرئيس في جزر البهاماس حاول مالكها
استرضاء المشرعين الامريكيين واصبح احد
كبار المانحين الرئيسيين للحزب الديمقراطي
استثمر بعمله صنعتها واسمتها افتيتي ووضعت
اموال المستثمرين فيها وهو امر اعابه
عليها قائلا لا نستخدم ابدا رمزا قمت
بانشائه كضمان
[موسيقى]
الغريب
استثمرت مبكرا في شركه اف تي اكس بل
واشترى عددا كبيرا من رموز افتيتي لكن
ملياردير
في شركتهما الان يتنازعان يتنازعان رسميا
على احتواء السوق هذا الاسبوع انتشر تقرير
استهدف الوضع الماليه
وخوفا من خساره اموالهم سحب المستثمرون
اكثر من سته مليارات دولار من بورصه اكس
على مدى ثلاثه ايام تاركين شركه تصارع
للحصول على السيوله لتغطيه التزاماتها
حاول موظفه المستثمرون فيها عبثا فهم ما
حدث ليكتب رساله اعتذار الى المستثمرين
قال فيها انا اسف لانني لم افعل ما هو
افضل اثار الانهيار المفاجئ لافته الكثير
من الاسئله مستقبل العملات المشفره ماذا
سيحدث لعملاء افتياكس مثلا ولاموالهم قد
يترك المستثمرون للقتال من اجل اموالهم او
ما تبقى منها في المحاكم ثم الاهم هل
سيؤذن انهيار افتي اكس الى فشل اوسع في
السوق كما فعل انهيار لمن راديس في 2008
في العالم ماليا حتى الان لا يعرف حجمه
الضرر الحقيقي فبالنظر الى ماذا تشابك افت
اكس مع بقيه اقتصاد العمله المشفره عند
انتشار اخبار افتي اكس انخفضت اسعار
بيتكوين واثيرم على حد سواء وانخفض سعر
العمره العمله سولانا المشفره التي دعمتها
اكس بنسبه 20%
[موسيقى]
لكن يبقى داعمون العملات المشفره يحدثهم
الامل بانه هو على عكس 2008 فان تداعيات
انهيار ستظل تحت السيطره في الغالب في
صناعه العملات الرقميه لكن لا يزال من
السابق لاوانه معرفه ذلك ايضا حتى هذا
الاسبوع كان باتمان ملك العملات المشفره
بلا منازع وقوه متزايده نفوذ في الولايات
المتحده
مع 15 مليار دولار ثروه اليوم خسر الرجل
ما يصل الى
94% من ثروته اي لم يعد مليارديرا ولا
مؤثرا سياسيا هي نهايه رجل شجاع اذا او
شاب شجاع الا اذا وصل سوق العملات المشفره
جنون